est ce qu'on sait embobiner avec la
fibre recyclée des fabricants se drape
de vertus écolo en disant que leur
manteau proviennent de bouteilles de
plastique usagées le petit gap indique
fièrement qu'ils contiennent du
polyester recyclé mais l'étiquette
requise par la loi juste à côté
indiquent qu'ils sont faits de matériaux
neufs seulement l'information vous
semble décousue en réalité pour passer
d'une bouteille de plastique adjudant de
polyester il ya tellement d'étaples
transformation que le produit final est
considéré comme un matériau 9 toute
façon mais à la demande de l'industrie
du vêtement et de l'industrie du
recyclage
les provinces ont cessé d'exiger que les
matériaux de rembourrage soit 9 la
fameuse étiquette matériaux n'oeuvre pas
donc disparaître une certaine confusion
aussi les fabricants pourront donc dû
passer leur message sans que l'autre
étiquette vous fasse perdre
passé le monde